c'est la planification écologique dont
on va parler avec une première mesure
annoncée par Elisabeth borne un fond
vert doté de 1,5 milliards d'euros à
destination des collectivités locales
Jonathan du prière
c'est dans un entretien au Parisien le
28 août dernier que la première ministre
annoncé le déblocage d'un fond vert un
milliard 5 d'euros destiné au
collectivités pour les aider à lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique cela
leur permettra de mettre en place des
solutions pour réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et s'adapter au
changement climatique selon Elisabeth
borne se font pourraient permettre de
réhabiliter des friches végétaliser les
villes créer des parkings relais ou
encore rénover l'isolation des bâtiments
publics mais ces mesures ont été
accueillies fraîchement par les
associations d'élus a commencé par
l'Association des maires de France si la
MF sur le principe accueille avec un
intérêt positif l'annonce d'un
financement accru pour la transition
écologique des collectivités elle
constate d'une part que rien n'est dit
sur les obligations des collectivités
d'autre part qu'elle n'a pas été
associée au travail en amont de ce
dispositif à ce stade les collectivités
s'interroge toujours sur la répartition
de ce fond entre les communes et les
départements mais aussi sur son
calendrier cette mesure gouvernementale
n'a pas été votée lors du projet de loi
de finance rectificative avant l'été et
devrait être intégré dans le plan
d'action à plus long terme sur la
planification écologique la première
ministre le présentera dans le courant
de l'automne
tirez les leçons d'un été canicule et
engagés pour de bon une planification
écologique digne de ce nom c'est un
chantier majeur de la rentrée pour en
débattre j'accueille Magali regazzi
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes maître de
conférence en géographie à l'école
nomade supérieure Léa Falco bonjour
bienvenue vendredi du collectif pour un
réveil écologique Patrice geoffronte
soir bienvenue professeur d'économie à
Paris Dauphine directeur du centre de
géopolitique de l'énergie et des
matières premières Mathieu croissanto et
Italie politique est toujours à
m'écouter évidemment alors on rebondit
sur le sujet qu'on vient de voir
ensemble ce fond vert là un milliard et
demi de débloquer pour les collectivités
alors on peut se dire que c'est beaucoup
d'argent où on peut se dire est-ce que
c'est suffisant face à l'immensité des
défis qu'est-ce que vous en pensez c'est
déjà ça mais c'est vrai que c'est ça va
être très vite insuffisant parce
qu'effectivement les enjeux sont énormes
on a des enjeux qui sont des enjeux
immédiats de réponse à l'urgence qui est
une urgence économique qui va très vite
devenir social et déjà dans un certain
nombre de communes on a aussi des
catastrophes naturelles qui se sont
multipliées il va falloir y faire face à
un moment donné et puis derrière on a
les mesures d'atténuation qui va falloir
absolument engager et le Conseil l'a
rappelé dans son dernier rapport on a on
a fait des efforts mais ça va pas
suffisamment vite il va falloir
accélérer et puis là on est au pied du
mur parce que ce qui s'est passé depuis
en fait le mois de janvier on voit bien
qu'on va devoir aussi faire face aux
conséquences de ce changement climatique
donc c'est les mesures d'adaptation plus
la crise énergétique qui d'une certaine
manière touche les deux parce que dans
cette transition qu'on appelle
écologique et qui en réalité une
transition sociale une transition
économique une transition juridique
enfin ça touche tous les domaines et ben
il va falloir l'énergie joue un rôle
fondamental et donc c'est vrai que tout
ça d'une certaine façon on a
l'impression qu'on est contrat
aujourd'hui d'engager cette transition
alors que ça fait quand même plus de 30
ans que les choses sont posées sur la
table que le premier rapport du GIEC à
rappeler et les États membres du GIEC
ont adopté l'idée qu'il fallait agir bon
on se retrouve dans une situation
aujourd'hui ou c'est la crise
énergétique qui nous oblige à changer
sauf qu'elles nous oblige avec le
couteau sous la gorge et les
collectivités territoriales pour
conclure elles sont vraiment en bout de
chaîne c'est à dire que c'est elle qui
sont en direct sur les problèmes celles
qui sont en direct avec les habitants
avec les activités avec tout ce qui est
en train de s'effondrer en poste covid
il faut quand même rappeler aussi qu'on
a vécu deux années terribles pour ses
collectivités et finalement la crise
aujourd'hui il faut pas prendre les
choses à l'envers elle ne fait que
révéler les fragilités accumulées et
nous dire que si on n'agit pas ça va
encore être plus grave dans les années
prochaines effectivement avec je le
disais en titre c'est c'est à la fois
l'urgence l'urgence aussi liée à cet été
de catastrophe et puis ce temps long ce
temps de planification qui est
nécessaire avec des choix qui nous
engagent pour plusieurs décennies
évidemment les alphaco si on essaye de
rester sur les collectivités
territoriales et peut-être les les
priorités on sait pas encore exactement
comment cet argent va être distribué
selon quels critères voilà c'est encore
un peu flou on parle beaucoup par
exemple de rénovation des bâtiments
c'est peut-être ça la priorité les
passoires thermiques dans les
collectivités locales alors la
difficulté de la situation c'est que on
a pu vraiment le temps de hiérarchiser
et qu'il va falloir engager tout un tas
de chantiers en même temps sur le fond
vert c'est 1,5 milliards il faut aussi
voir d'où ils sont pris et comment ils
vont trouver organiser on a a priori
d'après les dernières des informations
qu'on ait eu tout à fait d'accord avec
vous jusque là c'est clair pour personne
il y aurait 900 millions qui seraient
nouveaux qui seraient donc un nouveau de
fondation qui serait inscrit au plan de
loi finances 2023 et il y en aurait donc
le reste j'ai 600 millions sur le 1
milliard 5 qui viendrait d'un fond qui
existe déjà qui s'appelle la dotation de
soutien à l'investissement local donc
important aussi à savoir que il y a tout
un tout un tas de stratification pour
les collectivités et que la manière dont
ça fonctionne généralement pour elle
c'est sous forme de d'appel d'offres
d'appel à projet qui leur prend
énormément de temps en interne à
construire à monter à développer à
soutenir auprès de l'organe qui porte
cet appel à projet il faut avoir une
commune suffisamment
une communauté de communes pour pouvoir
répondre à un appel d'offre absolument
ou alors il faut externaliser et là
c'est un autre problème aussi qu'on a au
centre des collectivités locales qui est
que très souvent on fait appel à des
cabinets de conseils à des ingénieries
extérieures alors qu'on pourrait avoir
si on mettait les financements de la
capacité en interne pour le faire donc
vrai point d'attention là-dessus et sur
la question de de alors sur les 10
dernières années le on a eu je crois 37
milliards qui ont été affectés il
faudrait vérifier mais je crois que
c'est 37 milliards qui ont été affectés
spécifiquement à l'année rénovation
thermique des bâtiments on sait que
c'est pas assez qu'il va falloir
poursuivre et que c'est 1,5 milliards
qu'on a d'autres données aujourd'hui
d'après d'après Elizabeth borne au
collectivité locale c'est en fait pas
suffisant on va certainement en parler
et dire qu'il va falloir mettre plus sur
la table mais d'après le l'Institut de
l'économie pour le climat il faudrait en
fait presque 10 milliards par an
d'investissement pour les collectivités
c'est deux à trois fois plus que
qu'aujourd'hui donc il y a un vrai
mouvement en avant qui doit se faire
si on fait toujours sur ce fond il y a
aussi la question de la temporalité bon
alors en même temps c'est déjà bien
qu'il arrive là mais il arrive forcément
trop tard dans mon métier dans notre
métier ce qu'on appelle une session de
rattrapage la mois de septembre c'est
généralement à ce moment-là que ça
s'organise et bon donc évidemment il
faut prendre toute une série de mesure
dans l'urgence et ça en fait partie donc
on va pas galvauder ce milliard et demi
maintenant si on veut avoir des ordres
de grandeur faire la transition à la
avec la bonne temporalité qui va
supposer de réduire les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de 55% 2030 c'est pas
très loin là on est à - 20% à l'heure
actuelle à peu près comparativement
l'année de référence qui est 1990 ça va
supposer de manière constante d'investir
à peu près 4% du PIB par année on est à
peu près la moitié on nous alentours de
de 2% 4% ça fait 100 milliards donc si
vous m'invitez pour m'enthousiasmer avec
ce milliard et demi ça va être un peu
difficile même si évidemment il faut il
faut essayer de l'argent public à
fortiori il faut surtout ne rien
galvauder un autre élément de
comparaison et dès lors qu'on est au
cœur de la crise il me paraît important
de différents références lorsqu'on aura
fait le bilan de l'année 2022 il est
assez probable que les gels tarifaires
soient les tricités sur le gaz préalable
moins 30 centimes au moment où nous
parlons plus qu' est demandé par
ailleurs à total donc tout ça
additionner va peser de l'ordre
probablement de 40 milliards donc voilà
comparativement ce milliard et demi si
on veut avoir des éléments de
comparaison voilà c'est significatif
mais mais à l'évidence c'est un une
décision qui a été prise dans l'urgence
alors néanmoins qui a son importance et
ça a été dit il y a beaucoup de ce qui
va se jouer dans cette transition qui va
se jouer à une maille micro locale
lorsqu'on va vouloir accélérer le
déploiement de photovoltaïques par
exemple on va aller trouver sans doute
du foncier du foncier en toiture par
exemple et tout ça va jouer localement
on a une stabilité au fil du temps qui
est assez tragique sur les émissions
liées au transport l'aménagement des
systèmes de transport en organisant de
la multimodalité et des choses
intelligentes qui procèdent pas
uniquement du véhicule électrique ça se
joue également une local et puis ça a
déjà été dit abondamment évidemment il y
a le grand grand chantier du bâtiment
dans lequel on identifie les voies et
moyens localement voilà donc il va
falloir commune qui peut dire j'ai tel
bâtiment qui qui est une passoire
thermique et la priorité elle est là si
je suis très concret quoi tout à fait
mais pour annoncer la suite et j'espère
qu'on en parlera ce qui est ce dont ce à
quoi il va falloir qu'on raisonne
collectivement c'est sur le rendement de
ces investissements oui encore une fois
si on avait investi beaucoup plus par le
passé en se porterait considérablement
mieux mais pas simplement par rapport au
défi climatique mais également et
économiquement et socialement on y
viendra évidemment je vous propose
d'accueillir en duplex Sébastien Leroy
Kemer de
Mandelieu-la-Napoule et qui est qu'au
président du groupe de travail risque de
la MF l'Association des maires de France
vous nous raconterez tout à l'heure tout
ce que vous avez fait dans votre commune
depuis les pluies diluviennes de 2015 et
2019 mais je voudrais vous entendre vous
aussi en tant qu'élu local sur ce fond
vert là ce milliard et demi d'euros vous
en pensez quoi pas est-ce que vous
préparez déjà un candidater comment vous
réagissez
bonsoir et bien écoutez comme vous nous
avons est-ce qu'on peut déplorer
à aucun moment en amont et qu'ailleurs
où on se parle on a aucune précision sur
ces modalités d'application et le
problème c'est que par expérience
surtout les fonds qui ont pu être
débloqués par divers organismes d'état
par le passé on est toujours soumis à
des règles de candidature qui ne laisse
pas le temps matériel de préparer les
dossiers qui ne laisse pas le temps
matériel de les mettre en oeuvre et
beaucoup de collectivités vont soit pas
les moyens du candidatés soit mon tout
simplement pas le temps vous font pas
éligi il faudrait presque avoir
aujourd'hui les dossiers Fists prêts
exécutés sur lesquels ces notations
viendraient arriver en soutien et ça
voudrait dire qu'elles ont déjà été très
programmées et financé parce que
contrairement à l'État les collectivités
locales ne peuvent pas emprunter pour
fonctionner on est soumis à la règle
d'or donc ces opérations ça n'avait pas
été déjà été
uggés par le passé parce que aucune
opération est payée à 100% parfait faut
toujours que la commune amende et bien
si elles n'ont pas été prévus en amont
il est peu probable qu'elle le soit dans
les prochains exercices bud aujourd'hui
on est déjà dans la conclusion de des
petits budgets donc c'est une annonce
qu'à mon sens à beaucoup plus d'effet de
communication et on y fera du temps et
préfectif sur le terrain mais si une
partie de cet argent arrive dans les
caisses de votre ville prioritairement
vous faites quoi
alors encore une fois tout va dépendre
de quels seront
les clips comme information par terre
c'est que c'est un milliard et demi ils
vont être découpés en moins de trois
enveloppes différents de 500 millions
qui seront ciblés sur des sur des
budgets précis c'est-à-dire que ça peut
être de la rénovation de bâtiments qui
nécessite encore d'avoir une étude
préalable d'avoir lancé un appel d'offre
d'avoir des candidats additionnés et un
calendrier d'applications mais ça veut
dire que par exemple pour être éligible
il faut que vous ayez fait les travaux
dans les 6 à 8 mois ou encore et bien
malheureusement il y a beaucoup de
villes qui candidat accompagne cette
année donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on
peut faire de la rénovation énergétique
de l'amélioration naturellement on peut
faire de la végétalisation que ce soit
des cours d'école des places mais encore
une fois faut que les opérations soient
fistées nous on a des opérations de ce
type qui ont déjà en cours d'études et
de près réalisation ça pourrait être
abandonné si c'était nigible mais comme
je n'ai aucun des critères de sélection
à ce stade je ne peux pas vous répondre
intéressant d'avoir votre témoignage
revient vers vous tout à l'heure pour
parler de ce que vous avez mis en place
après
c'est plus diluvienne ces catastrophes
malheureusement mortel dans votre dans
votre ville cette émission elle repose
aussi sur la qualité des reportages de
la rédaction de Public Sénat et je vous
propose tout de suite un éclairage pour
voir que dans de nombreuses huiles
évidemment on n'a pas attendu le fond
vert annoncé par Elisabeth borne exemple
a Besançon des places des cours d'école
rénovées végétalisés pour mieux faire
face aux fortes chaleurs Jérémy
c'est l'un des carrefours les plus
fréquentés de Besançon ou la chaleur se
fait vite sentir pas de quoi pourtant
empêcher abeilles et papillon de butiner
ces plantes vivaces on a les nez pétales
lysope la sarriette on a eu deux mois de
canicule qui viennent de qui viennent de
passer et c'est massifs n'ont pas été
arrosés pas du tout juste à la
plantation mais pas depuis et là on a
des plantes qui ont déjà reverdi qui ont
pas grillé cet été des espèces plus
résistantes moins gourmandes en eau et
idéal pour faire baisser la température
on constate jusqu'à 20 degrés d'écart
entre des surfaces en enrobé comme une
route comme un trottoir et puis des
surfaces vertes comme celle-ci c'est 20
degrés d'écart il provoque aussi un
mouvement d'air et ces circulations
d'air et le participe du
rafraîchissement de la ville un îlot de
fraîcheur sur cette place mais aussi
dans la cour de cette école rénovée l'an
dernier
pour que les enfants et les maîtres
puissent venir se poser là à l'extérieur
faire classe dehors un espace de 5000
mètres carrés en grande partie
végétalisée et qui possède des
revêtements plus adaptés aux fortes
chaleurs
sauf que l'eau passe à travers et puis
on est vraiment sur un sol qui est
perméable également de l'eau qui va
pouvoir s'évaporer du sol et participer
aussi à cette régulation de la
température l'objectif rafraîchir mais
aussi ramener la biodiversité au contact
des plus jeunes maintenant elles disent
pas qui vont dans la cour ils disent
qu'ils vont dans le parc et on change en
soins de notre référentiel pour avoir
des espaces qui effectivement puissent
être plus résilients au total la
rénovation a coûté 650 000 euros à la
commune dans cette école voisine c'est
la structure du bâtiment qui vient
d'être en partie au fait sur ce bâtiment
là on avait des apports de de chaleur
directement dans les classes donc qui
devenait surchauffer mais si on va avoir
dans devrait pouvoir viser des
températures à peu près constante
compatibles avec un enseignement de
qualité grâce notamment aux toit et au
store qui protègent les salles des
rayons directs du soleil et à
l'intérieur on a à peu près 20 cm
d'épaisseur de laine de bois donc un
matériau biosourcis qui nous permet non
seulement d'assurer une bonne isolation
thermique mais aussi une bonne isolation
phonique des travaux chiffrés à 2,5
millions d'euros qui devrait permettre
une réduction de 60 % des consommations
énergétiques de l'école a Besançon le
changement climatique a été anticipé
mais beaucoup restent à faire comme sur
cette place du centre-ville au
revêtement très minéral créant un
véritable
îlot de chaleur en plein été il y a
entre la rivière et le point le plus
rouge il y a 20 degrés différents alors
chaque année la ville investit 45
millions d'euros pour accélérer la
transition écologique mais selon la mer
il faut aider davantage les
collectivités et aller plus loin que le
fond vert annoncé par le gouvernement on
est limité par un budget
et ça veut dire aussi que si les
entreprises ne participent pas si
l'ensemble de la société ne bouge pas on
n'arrivera pas à aller assez vite il
faudrait qu'on ait beaucoup plus de
moyens pour répondre aux enjeux
d'aujourd'hui donc les amis quelques
sont importants mais ils seront
largement insuffisants pour répondre à
l'urgence dans laquelle nous sommes une
urgence plus difficile à prendre en
charge aujourd'hui selon elle à cause
notamment de la flambée des prix de
l'énergie
voilà pour ce reportage qui clôt notre
premier chapitre sur le fond vert
maintenant aller plus loin dans l'action
peut mener le gouvernement en termes de
transe de transition de planification
pardon c'est le terme que je cherchais
planification écologique et Mathieu il y
a un homme un ministre qui est censé
être au cœur du de du dispositif c'est
Chris Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires mais depuis sa nomination on
se demande un peu oui passé Christophe
Béchu que fait Christophe Béchu voir qui
est Christophe Béchu nommé la tête du
portefeuille le plus stratégique d'un
quinquennat qui serait écologique ne
sera pas pour apprendre les mots
d'Emmanuel Macron le ministre de la
transition écologique surprend par son
effacement c'est un ministre très
discret qui trait il y a une semaine le
Courrier de l'Ouest le quotidien qu'on
lit à Angers la ville dont il a été
maire pendant 8 ans bon j'ai regardé son
agenda pour cette semaine alors il y
avait une vingtaine de rendez-vous
d'entretien pour certains sont qualifiés
d'audience c'est par exemple le Martine
vassal la présidente du en général des
Bouches-du-Rhône donc du matin au soir
Christophe Béchu consulte presque autant
qu'un médecin non conventionné mais pour
soigner le climat en revanche on
repassera parce que cet été alors que le
pays connaissait un épisode caniculaire
des incendies et épouvantables alors
qu'Emmanuel Macron Gérald Darmanin
faisait de la com sur le terrain se
rendait sur place en Gironde Christophe
véchu ne change rien à ses consultation
c'est pas la présence du ministre aux
côtés des sapeurs-pompiers qui modifient
le drame que nous sommes en train de
vivre se défendaient-ils au micro de RTL
c'est pas faux la présence des ministres
sur le terrain parfois c'est c'est bien
encombrant mais ce n'ont pas ce ne sont
pas non plus cette décision qui risque
de changer la donne le 27 juillet le
ministre annonçait des mesures de lutte
contre les incendies 300000 euros pour
les campagnes de prévention en plus au
mois d'août et une idée qui livrait à
notre réflexion c'est son nom la
création d'une météo des forêts pour
rappeler aux Français que quand on a des
épisodes caniculaires des épisodes de
sécheresse ça n'est pas le moment
d'aller se promener en forêt la belle
affaire alors est-ce qu'on le voit
davantage depuis la rentrée non mais il
faut dire à sa décharge que sur le
créneau de l'écologie il a de la
concurrence celle du président de la
République tout d'abord qu'on a fait des
thèmes de son conseil national de leur
information tient demain celle de la
première ministre Elisabeth borne
ensuite c'est elle qui a appelé par
exemple les patrons à la sobriété devant
l'université d'études mulet quand lui
Christophe Béchu se charger du service
après-vente celle de sa collègue Agnès
panier en acier ministre de la
transition énergétique c'est elle par
exemple qui portera le prochain projet
de loi sur le plan d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables il a même subi la
concurrence médiatique de son ministre
délégué au transport Clément baume qui
s'est interrogé fin août sur la possible
la nécessaire ou non les régulations des
jets privés là c'était la goutte d'eau
de trop pour Christophe Béchu qui a
aussitôt rappelé à l'ordre son ministre
délégué en déclarant que l'écologie ce
n'est pas le buzz pas faux là encore
mais on rappellera à ce politique
chevronné qui était pas un spécialiste
de l'environnement que l'écologie c'est
pas non plus le monde du silence merci
Mathieu Magali règles
au-delà de la personnalité de Christophe
et je suis la question de la la place de
la planification écologique au sein de
ce gouvernement pourquoi c'est central
ces centrales parce que le problème
c'est qu'on appelle ça planification
écologique en réalité si on entend comme
écologie un peu cette idée on aime les
lapins et tout ça c'est plus le sujet
enfin je suis désolé
en gros on est toujours sur les verres
qui mangent du boulegour qui roulent à
vélo contre le réalisme économique qui
fait du profit donc en fait on vit dans
un monde aujourd'hui cliver qui ne prend
pas en compte la réalité de ce qu'est la
transition la transition c'est quoi ce
sont des changements profonds de mode de
vie de mode de production et de
consommation pour faire cette transition
on a aujourd'hui un diagnostic sur le
problème il est posé par la science
c'est le RAF le fameux rapport
d'évaluation du GIEC qui fait cette
revue de littérature scientifique pour
nous dire où on va en fonction des
trajectoires et le GIEC a aussi évalué
l'ensemble des solutions qui existent
une fois qu'on a ça en fait on a rien
c'est à dire que on sait où on veut
aller c'est la neutralité carbone en
2050 ça on le sait si on n'atteint pas
on va arriver à des seuil de température
qui vont être extrêmement difficiles à
vivre y compris pour les Français ça se
passe pas juste au Pakistan ça va se
passer chez nous dans nos territoires ça
se passe
exactement et donc derrière ensuite
c'est transformation avec des solutions
et des panachasses et des orientations
donc ça veut dire que dans tous les
ministères ça doit être intégré quoi
avant même cette deuxième en nature de
d'Emmanuel Macron le Haut Conseil pour
le climat avait dit il faut que cette
transition soit dans tous les ministères
et il avait demandé à tous les
ministères des Plans Climat il faut un
portage politique il faut une vision
interministérielle pourquoi parce qu'en
fait cette planification cette vision
générale cette stratégie elle va se
faire au ministère de la Santé au
ministère de l'éducation au ministère du
Travail évidemment à Bercy au ministère
des Transports dans tous les secteurs en
réalité presque en dehors du ministère
de l'écologie au sens strict même si ce
ministère va devoir gérer en particulier
la prévention des risques et on revient
à Mandelieu parce qu'on voit que là on a
une urgence d'adaptation l'énergie
évidemment donc en fait être mis en
place et mis en musique et ensuite la
déclinaison elle est territoriale et
c'est là toute la difficulté c'est à
dire qu'en fait on voit des strates
aujourd'hui qui s'empilent entre ce
qu'on a vu dans votre reportage ça va
être la place l'appartement le bâtiment
c'est du pointillisme mais c'est comme
ça que ça marche et ça et on prouve que
ça fonctionne et donc en fait c'est la
logique d'un état c'est-à-dire qu'on a
un état stratège en état pilote qui doit
effectivement accompagner et là aussi je
refais de la publicité pour ce rapport
du Haut Conseil pour le climat mais
c'est écrit on l'écrit on le répète on
voit les ministres pour leur dire on a
besoin d'un accompagnement des
collectivités et donc cette transition
effectivement elle est dans tous les
secteurs et elle n'est pas donnée mais
alors c'est intéressant si vous dites
parce qu'il y a la question de la
formation des des membres du
gouvernement Léa Falco on sait que lors
du séminaire gouvernemental de rentrer
il y a la scientifique l'une des
scientifiques du GIEC Valérie maçonner
le mode qui a passé je sais pas
peut-être deux heures avec eux mais 30
minutes ah bon ben voilà c'était j'étais
très optimiste
on est très très loin d'une formation on
est très loin d'une formation
il faut qu'on parle tous le même langage
d'une certaine façon parce que le
rapport du GIEC il est massif il est
complexe pourquoi c'est important que
nos dirigeants les les digérer les
intégrer il y avait eu il y a quelques
semaines ou quelques mois peut-être même
maintenant une pétition qui avait été
signée par un certain nombre de
scientifiques et d'experts sur les
sujets climat et environnement qui
demandaient à ce que le gouvernement et
les équipes gouvernementales soient
formés sur ces sujets là à raison de 20
heures de formation ce qui peut paraître
beaucoup mais qui en fait au vu de
l'aspect systémique et multi sectorielle
des transformations à implémenter et
finalement un strict minimum et
Elisabeth borne a la remise de ce fameux
rapport du Haut Conseil pour le climat
dont je fais la publicité également il
faut absolument lire au moins le résumé
Elisabeth borne s'était engagée à d'un
côté former ces équipes ministérielles
de l'autre former tous les
fonctionnaires en commençant par les
fonctionnaires de catégories A donc les
fonctionnaires qui sont cadres dans la
fonction publique pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut absolument former parce que d'une
partie le gouvernement
et probablement au courant d'une partie
de ce qui se passe là on est sur un
sujet brûlant évidemment que eux ont des
probablement des conseillers qui leur
écrivent des fiches des éléments de
langage et tout un tas de choses qui
peuvent réciter pendant leur discours
mais nous on a besoin d'une garantie qui
est de savoir que s'ils ne prennent pas
les décisions qui incombe aujourd'hui à
l'heure de l'urgence écologiste ce sera
un choix politique et ce sera pas une
absence de connaissance aujourd'hui on a
encore cette incertitude et c'est à ça
que sert la formation c'est pas
suffisant mais c'est absolument
nécessaire parce que ça emmène vers le
moment où on pourra dire au gouvernement
et à l'étape largement vous savez ce qui
se passe vous n'agissez pas il n'y a pas
d'autre raison que une absence de
volonté politique et pour revenir sur la
question de Christophe bécher
j'entends la possibilité d'une action en
justice il y a déjà eu des actions en
justice pour les chats français pour une
action climatique donc je pense pas
encore que ce soit accessoire on est au
tout début en fait on parle de
transition écologique depuis plusieurs
années mais on est au tout début de la
transition écologique on est encore au
stade des discours et du déblocage de
public donc là on est encore à les nulle
part c'est important de le réaliser
aussi même si on est plutôt dans un dans
un contexte positif où on expose de plus
en plus les enjeux environnementaux mais
il y a vraiment cette question de
responsabilité étatique à un stade où on
sait que les entreprises ne peuvent pas
toutes seules se dégager du carcan
concurrentiel dans lequel elles sont ça
doit forcément passer par une action
quelle qu'elle soit du gouvernement mais
Patrice jouffront il y a quand même une
opportunité c'est enfin une crise c'est
toujours une opportunité on peut aussi
voir cette crise énergétique que l'on
vit comme une vraie opportunité
politique notamment pour Emmanuel Macron
je pense que ce second mandat il leur a
réussi si
il réussit à emmener le pays dans cette
transition écologique énergétique et
pourquoi il y a une opportunité
aujourd'hui d'après vous qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire accepter aux Français
difficile de parler voilà avec une forme
d'enthousiasme même si au fond de moi
c'est ma conviction de cette opportunité
parce qu'elle est quand même le produit
d'atrocité et du Christ qui va
évidemment arriver jusqu'à nous mais de
si on veut être très très prosaïque
premièrement désormais on a une taxe
carbone la question de la taxe carbone
c'était de parvenir à installer un prix
élevé évidemment pour les énergies
fossiles et globalement d'avoir un
signal prix moi je suis économique j'en
suis désolé qui qui nous conduisent à
voilà prendre des décisions qui
permettent d'intégrer la contrainte et
ce prix désormais on l'a qu'on l'attend
ça veut dire ça pour les Français
laisser l'essence chair quand elle est
chère alors ça veut dire que évidemment
dans tout ce qui s'est passé dans
l'urgence on peut imaginer surtout qu'en
sortie de covid il y a un certain nombre
de décisions qui étaient prises de telle
manière à ce que on ait le temps de
réfléchir au travers du choc il y a
quand même un certain nombre de trucs
qui coincent et notamment les 30
centimes notamment les 30 centimes et a
fortiori évidemment dans les conditions
dans lesquelles tout ça c'est noué ce
qui me semble pas faire de sens et puis
plus globalement si on regarde la
manière dont a été allouée l'effort
collectif en termes de soutien lorsqu'on
fera le bilan de l'année ça j'ai déjà
mentionné on se sera sans doute à 40
milliards
globalement d'argent public parce que
tout ça va aller se mécaniquement se
loger dans la dette publique de de
blocage de différentes tarifs ou de
ristourne à la pompe et bien il va
falloir qu'on aborde mécaniquement 2023
dans les conditions différentes avec
plus de ciblage parce que c'est pas un
effort qu'on va pouvoir soutenir sur la
durée et de fait les décisions étaient
prises comme si on était en présence
d'une crise transitoire alors qu'en fait
on est au début d'une nouvelle période
c'est absurde que un cadre supérieur
qu'il gagne très bien sa vie qui roule
en SUV bénéficie des 30 centimes de
risques tournent quoi oui d'ailleurs ça
aussi entre les deux tours était un
point de convergence entre les candidats
et candidates qui étaient en finale
l'élection présidentielle c'est un point
sur lequel il s'était entendu mais de
fait c'est pas la manière dont les
choses se sont noués ensuite mais à
l'Assemblée vous dites je reste avec
vous qu'on va pouvoir aligner nos
intérêts économiques et environnementaux
pourquoi vous dites alors aligné ils
sont alignés malgré nous mais de fait
désormais ils sont alignés il y a pas
d'ambiguïté en fait ce qu'on découvre
assez violemment c'est qu'on est le
premier groupe de pays avoir 19ème
siècle on a brûlé à peu près la totalité
de notre pétrole et notre gaz si on veut
dire les choses rapidement on est
extrêmement dépendant de toute une série
de pays avec lesquels on n'a pas
toujours les relations commerciales et
amicales qu'on a avec la Norvège et donc
on découvre cette dépendance et ce qui
fait que désormais on a un intérêt
économique un intérêt environnemental et
un intérêt de sécurité collective qui
ces trois intérêts sont parfaitement
alignés
étaient de catastrophe je le disais en
bonissait sur cette actualité je reviens
vers vous Sébastien Leroy à
mandelieu-la-napoude ça ça vous a
forcément rappelé de très mauvais
souvenirs c'est plus ils viennent qu'on
frappait mortellement votre ville en
2015 et puis encore d'autres plus
diluvienne en 2019 là on va être très
concret aussi avec vous ce qui est
intéressant c'est de savoir ce que vous
avez mis en place depuis pour protéger
les habitants
alors tout à fait c'est vrai que les
intempéries de 2015 et 2019 ont été
véritablement révélateur profond de ce
que nous allons vivre dans les
prochaines années très rapidement pour
revenir sur ce qui a été mis et que je
partage pleinement sur votre plateau et
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une double
problématique en France c'est-à-dire à
la fois bien sûr financière pour les
collectivités qui n'ont pas de
visibilité
régulièrement mais elle est aussi
règlementaires il faut savoir que le
système digital français aujourd'hui le
permet plus d'agir concrètement
rapidement sur le terrain à Mandelieu
nous avons l'interface avec des filles
qui sont considérables c'est-à-dire que
nous devons réinventer une ville sur la
ville sur un territoire de la Côte
d'Azur qui était surnomalisé sans aucune
réflexion en aucune prise en compte des
risques naturels donc aujourd'hui l'idée
c'est quoi se réécrire le faire
naturellement de la désintérisation des
sols que ce soit dans les cours d'école
comme on peut y comme ce que j'ai vu à
Besançon
également de faire des aménagements
extrêmement larges je vous donne un
exemple par 14 hectares en centre-ville
et là on rejoint la problématique
faire c'est que pour arriver à débloquer
le dossier qui était depuis quasiment 30
ans il a fallu mettre en place une tasse
que force avec les services de l'État
avec tous les acteurs avec Eric Daniel
Macron qui est un architecte avec la
Direction générale des risques majeurs
pour vous un an arriver à avancer mais à
côté de ça vous avez des projets de
bassin de rétention qui sont paralysés
depuis 15 ans tout simplement parce que
on est toujours dans une gestion de
norme et que on ne s'en sort pas parce
que le droit français est arrivé dans un
tel état d'incohérence puis
réglementation superposent il paraît
absolument toutes les volonté on a une
pesanteur des marchés publics et devenue
totalement incompréhensible et à côté de
ça en plus vous avez des injonctions
contradictoires de l'État je vous donne
un exemple sur la ligne de mon lieu où
on doit déconstruire pour refaire mieux
et libérer des espaces pour la nature
mais à côté de ça la loi et ses runes
qui peut faire des logements sociaux
vous avez cette loi qui donne la
possibilité à un magistrat d'annuler
votre PMU parce que les promoteur à
faire des bassins de rétention et qu'on
considère c'est un frein urbanisation et
que l'on vous renvoie 10 ans en arrière
on va aller on en reverbom le risque
naturel aujourd'hui c'est ça la réalité
et c'est ça que doit le comprendre à la
fois bien sûr le gouvernement devrait
lancer un chantier considérable de
simplification des normes en rendant de
pouvoir préférer au service de l'État
locaux mais on devrait aussi avoir un
travail législateur important qui je
déplore crise après crise ne prend pas
la mesure de ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
malgré tout ce qu'on a vécu et malgré
les dizaines qu'il y a eu absolument
rien n'a été fait pour simplifier la
législation française qui est encore une
fois je le dis je le répète et je
l'affirme empêche sur le terrain on les
collectivités locales d'agir que l'État
également qui se retrouve lui-même
bloqué par ses propres contradictions et
si on ne règle pas ça
finalement ne sont jamais utilisés parce
que les projets sont très beaux sur le
papier mais n'arrive jamais à exécution
à moins d'une quinzaine d'années et bien
on aura pris des effets de communication
et merci malheureusement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui je vous interromps pardon
magritz vous êtes d'accord c'est sur
cette complexité du droit qui peut
freiner finalement la transition qui est
pourtant urgente il y a au moins trois
freins ça a été dit le foncier qui
possède le sol parce qu'en fait derrière
c'est les enjeux d'aménagement du
territoire si vous n'avez pas le sol
alors il faut racheter enfin c'est très
compliqué deux effectivement c'est la
loi c'est-à-dire qu'en France on empile
on a un nombre de cibles absolument
invraisemblable en gros on a tout on a
les rapports on a les lois on a les
instruments sur la question des risques
naturels et à Mandelieu ils sont bien
passés pour le savoir on a les plans de
prévention des risques on a les papilles
on a faim on a des papillons les papiers
alors c'est les plans d'aménage enfin de
prévention des inondations on a les PSR
on a les pcaet on allaitra d'être pas
vous demander d'expliquer tous les
sigles on comprend bien qu'en fait c'est
ça demande une compétence technique déjà
qui est énorme et que et c'est le
troisième point toutes les collectivités
n'ont pas alors après on peut se dire
voilà face à l'urgence qu'est-ce qu'on
fait est-ce que on refait des
instruments avec des nouvelles lois avec
des nouveaux trucs est-ce qu'on
simplifie ou est-ce qu'on essaie
effectivement de rendre déjà efficace ce
qui existe en accompagnant les
collectivités et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a besoin de cette transition
juridique fiscale on a des collectivités
aujourd'hui qui ont des problèmes de
rentrée d'argent on le voit c'est ce que
disait aussi le maire de Mandelieu la
collectivité peut pas s'endetter donc
derrière on a des mécanismes qui sont
des mécanismes vertueux les marchés
publics c'est au départ vertueux mais
c'est vrai que derrière un projet
d'aménagement en gros c'est aujourd'hui
10 à 15 ans est-ce qu'il faut des lois
d'exception d'une certaine manière si on
considère que c'est une urgence
prioritaire je prends l'exemple des
éoliennes ou moi je suis un B aussi en
la matière mais on a l'impression qu'on
n'arrive pas à en construire parce qu'il
y a des milliers de recours contre ces
éoliennes est-ce qu'il y a un moment où
il faut dire ben non mais il y aura
plutôt recours c'est plus possible parce
qu'il faut que je donne cet exemple
c'est pas bon mais je vais plagi un qui
dit en fait les lois en France elles
sont assorties de toutes les conditions
de leur inefficacité c'est à dire qu'en
gros aujourd'hui vous avez des lois
magnifiques sur les plans de prévention
des risques moi j'ai beaucoup étudié ce
sujet là et ben de lui est vraiment en
plein dedans en fait le principe c'est
qu'on va tout faire quand même dans
toutes les qualités mais en contournant
la loi par des textes par des
dérogations par des dérogations à la
dérogation avec deux conséquences ça
coûte une fortune parce que derrière
c'est du content Superman donc à peine
vous prescriviez un plan de prévention
des risques il est contesté à droite à
gauche peu importe on le suspend pour
pouvoir construire ça devient délirant
et puis à côté il y a un sentiment
d'iniquité c'est à dire que d'une
commune à l'autre vous avez pas la règle
la même réglementation d'une commune à
l'autre vous avez pas la même aide et
derrière effectivement les collectivités
se mettent à devoir répondre à des
appels à projets sur appel à projet donc
on sait jamais si l'argent va arriver on
sait jamais si le projet va se faire et
quand le projet se fait effectivement il
faut aussi le temps vous exproprier pas
n'importe comment il faut trouver la
main d'oeuvre il faut trouver la
maîtrise d'ouvrage alors on a le cas de
Mandelieu qui est un cas extraordinaire
parce qu'effectivement un architecte qui
est très connu dans le domaine de la
résilience parce qu'il avait fait ce
quartier de Romorantin c'est Éric Daniel
Lacombe et on a travaillé élu architecte
avec des démarches participatives
collaboratives citoyens pour
effectivement se dire aujourd'hui nos
élus ils ont affaire face à trois types
d'héritage un urbanisme qu'ils n'ont pas
choisi c'est pas votre faute si on a
tout urbanisant on a densifié c'est pas
votre faute une législation qui est en
maquis ou en gros nous nos étudiants on
parle des étudiants la première partie
du mémoire c'est de nous faire un état
des lieux des différents documents qui
existent et c'est déjà en soi une partie
de l'année et ça change chaque année et
puis il y a aussi l'héritage de de
clivage de gouvernance sur les
territoires et on pourrait en parler
aussi sur les territoires agricoles avec
l'eau ou en fait on a des territoires où
ça marche bien parce qu'on a une
tradition de coopération et puis des
territoires où il y a des tensions
anciennes et donc les élus doivent
jongler avec tout ça il nous reste moins
de 10 minutes vous parliez de prévention
des risques forcément ça nous ramène à
cet
d'incendie malheureusement
des chiffres
d'hectares brûlés qu'on n'avait pas vu
depuis des décennies en France quand un
calmé vous allez nous rejoindre tout de
suite c'est cet été de feux de forêt il
appelle des renforts des moyens
supplémentaires pour la sécurité civile
pour les pompiers les services
départementaux d'incendie et de secours
le Sénat a publié un rapport sur ce
qu'on appelle les mégafeux oui c'est ça
qu'il y a eu plusieurs enseignements
avec ces incendies cet été déjà les
incendies qui ont touché des endroits
inhabituels on voit des images mi-août
des feux de forêt en Ille-et-Vilaine
c'est vrai que on s'attendait peut-être
pas avoir autant d'incendies en Bretagne
mais c'est la preuve que plus aucun
département français n'est à l'abri
c'est directement lié au réchauffement
climatique puisque les sécheresses comme
ça s'accumulent d'été en été des feux
particuliers aussi et ces deuxième
enseignements par leur intensité et avec
une saison des incendies potentiellement
toute l'année et plus simplement elle
était écoutez le constat réalisé par le
président de la Fédération des pompiers
c'était devant les sénateurs
effectivement quand ils travaillaient
mi-juin sur ses mégafeux écouter son
constat
puis 2019-2020 le dérèglement climatique
le changement climatique on l'a on le
vit au quotidien nous étions encore
avant-hier dans le Gard pour des feux
qui dépassent l'entendement alors qu'il
y avait très peu de vent ils prennent
une telle intensité une telle
intensité en matière de température que
vous l'avez entendu s'il n'y a pas de
séparation s'il n'y a pas de coupure de
végétation entre la forêt et les
éléments de lutte on ne peut pas aller
au contact pas tellement ils sont
puissants puissants et je pense que
notre collègue chercheur pourra vous
indiquer mais les puissances se situent
dans l'ordre des mégawatts c'est des
centrales nucléaires qui se déplacent
c'est presque prémonitoire ces propos
ont été tenus le 15 juin dernier mais
donc c'est une coïncidence de
l'actualité de l'été les sénateurs ont
fait 70 propositions remises début août
dans un rapport sur les méga feu comme
de revenir par exemple sur les 500
suppressions de postes à l'ONF ou encore
de soutenir les 10 effectivement les
services départementaux de secours les
sénateurs je parle d'augmenter je cite
significativement la dotation de soutien
de l'État à l'investissement de 16 10
pour l'équipement pour les camions par
exemple car justement on en parlait les
collectivités les départements ont en
première ligne et d'ailleurs ils sont à
l'initiative et séjour-ci l'Assemblée
des départements de France a lancé une
mission flash sur le sujet des mégafeux
on le voit le président du conseil
départemental de Saône-et-Loire de
Saône-et-Loire et celui de la Gironde
qui vont multiplier les déplacements ils
ont commencé hier pour aller dans les
zones touchées par les feux cet été et
leur conclusion Thomas elles seront
présentés fin septembre à Nancy au
congrès national des sapeurs-pompiers
merci Quentin pour toutes ces
explications Patrice geoffront les
départements est-ce qu'ils sont plus
riches que les communes pour faire face
à ce parce que là on dit il va falloir
plus de moyens pour les pompiers plus ou
moins pour la sécurité civile des
mégafeux on va sans doute en avoir sur
des périodes plus longues dans des
départements où il y avait pas de feu
auparavant est-ce que les départements
ont les moyens de le faire
j'ai pas les idées claires sur ce sujet
mais en tout cas ce qu'on a compris cet
été c'est que à l'évidence on n'était
pas outillés on nous a parlé quand même
notamment d'une flotte aérienne qui
était vieillissante qui allait être
complexe par ailleurs à recomposer et
sont des investissements qui vont
prendre du temps qui sont pas d'ailleurs
extrêmement coûteux surtout regard de
l'intérêt d'éviter de pouvoir intervenir
très rapidement sur ces feux mais ce
qu'on a compris et votre journaliste à
l'instant et j'ai trouvé extrêmement
clair sur ce point c'est qu'elle est
vidange ni dans la temporalité ni dans
la localisée en gestion géographique on
allait pouvoir fonder les moyens futurs
sur ce qu'on a pu observer au cours des
10 dernières années et ça va supposer
également très probablement la vue cet
été aussi des moyens de coopération
d'intervention en commun au niveau
européen dès lors qu'on est en présence
de mégafeu je suis pas spécialiste à
nouveau mais enfin j'ai bien compris
qu'il s'agissait pas exactement du même
objet que les feux déjà massifs qu'on
avait l'usage de rentrer auparavant donc
ça suppose également du moyen de
coordination différents mais alors vous
parliez tout à l'heure des
investissements et je reviens à cette
idée de d'urgence et de temps long il y
a des prix
à définir il y a des choix par exemple
sur le nucléaire à définir enfin
quels sont pour vous les investissements
prioritaires aujourd'hui alors il y a
plusieurs échelles il y a une échelle
qu'on est en train de découvrir qui est
celle de l'hiver prochain qui était pas
censé être un enjeu et être un effort
collectif tel que ça va l'être et là on
n'a pas énormément de leviers on
découvre la sobriété on découvre
lorsqu'on a écouté
Ursula wander lion au milieu de la
journée on découvre également une autre
notion qui est spécifiquement pour
l'électricité de parvenir à réduire la
consommation à peu près tout le temps
mais spécifiquement dans des moments de
pic là au moment où au moment où nous
sommes là on est en période donc je
pourrais vous suggérer l'après-midi
d'éteindre on aurait mauvaise mine mais
il va falloir il va falloir réagir à des
qui veut nous être transmis de
différentes manières notamment par
l'appli j'en profite pour en dire un mot
l'appli Ecowatt qui est celle qui est
proposée par RTE c'est l'opérateur de
transport d'électricité qui pourra nous
alerter dans des moments de tension qui
n'ont pas douté on traversera durant
durant l'hiver donc c'est un question
d'adaptation absolument essentielle et
dans le court terme précisément parce
qu'on est en session rattrapage on n'a
pas tellement d'autres leviers mais plus
on va avancer dans les dans les hivers à
venir plus on aura vu se développer il
suffit de jeter un oeil sur la manière
dont est structuré le plan ripower qui
est destiné à essayer de trouver des
substituts au 150 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz russe et sur ces 150
milliards on sait qu'on peut trouver du
gaz pour remplacer du gaz à hauteur de
40% et donc le reste ça va être des
renouvelables notamment des
renouvelables électriques on peut avoir
des effets de levier assez rapide sur le
le photovoltaïque évidemment sur
l'éolien c'est plus lent mais sur le le
photovoltaïque on a pu agir assez
rapidement naturellement les habitudes
de sobriété qu'on va prendre il va
falloir que ça devienne des habitudes de
vie pour toute la décennie et sans doute
au-delà et puis évidemment il va falloir
combiner tout ça et on peut avoir là
également des effets de levier assez
rapide sur des efforts d'efficacité dans
le bâtiment et notamment parce que ce
faisant on doit pouvoir mettre à l'abri
une partie de la population 5 millions
de ménages au moment où nous parlons qui
ont structurellement des difficultés à
faire face aux factures de gaz
d'électricité à la maison qui se
chauffent pas 19 degrés mais plutôt à 16
à 15 et évidemment il faut accélérer
l'effort les concernant dans la
perspective de cet hiver on peut
peut-être effectivement terminer
là-dessus les à la Falco il va il va
falloir accompagner en priorité celles
et ceux qui vont souffrir parce que ce
que vous décrivez c'est pour cet hiver
mais il y a tellement de mutations en
cours il y a des métiers qui vont
disparaître d'autres qu'on ne connaît
pas encore il va falloir accompagner
ceux qui sont les plus fragiles face à
cette transformation bien sûr et je
pense que le vrai enjeu de la transition
écologique déjà du fait évidemment de
transformer nos sociétés pour aller vers
plus de respect des limites planétaires
c'est cet aspect social là je pense que
les on en revient toujours au coeur du
sujet mais c'est le financement la vraie
question là on va avoir le plan de le
plan de loi finance 2023 qui va être
présenté à priori en septembre c'est
présenté avant le 6 octobre c'est
généralement enfin septembre et c'est ça
qui va falloir regarder parce que c'est
la tirelire de l'État c'est où sont les
investissements pour les prochains mois
pour les prochaines années et
potentiellement vers quoi on se dirige
donc on a déjà eu des éclaircissements
un petit peu avant mais il y a trois
aspects essentiels dans ce futur PLF et
dans les futurs investissements c'est
déjà plus d'argent parce que on sait
qu'aujourd'hui on est un stade où on a
besoin d'avoir un premier effet de
levier qui s'introduit part de
l'investissement massif dans certaines
infrastructures et en particulier à
certaines échelles de granularité dont
les collectivités territoriales il va
falloir que ce soit mieux utilisé et
c'est la question de l'efficacité dont
on parlait tout à l'heure de d'impuls
sur le plan juridique et sur le plan
technique de quel choix on fait en
matière de technologie qu'elles soient
en fait en matière de d'efficacité et de
redesign de de cette fonction là et
troisième c'est il faut que ce soit
utilisé de manière juste de manière
sociale et donc typiquement sur le
bouclier énergique dont on parlait tout
à l'heure il va falloir qu'on transforme
ce bouclier en des chèques énergies très
probablement ou un dispositif de ce type
il sera dirigé fléchés vers les
populations qui en ont le plus besoin
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'était passionnant
à bientôt dans ce sens public voilà je
vous dis un grand merci d'abord à demain
prochain rendez-vous
sensublique c'est 18h et rediffusion 22
heures et puis votre prochain
rendez-vous politique c'est dans la
matinale Oriane monsini qui reçoit Hervé
Marseille le président du groupe Union
centriste au Sénat belle soirée
[Musique]